Іванна і Наталія розшукують своїх зниклих безвісти рідних.
Жінки вийшли на вулиці з портретами близьких,
аби отримати бодай якусь інформацію про їхню долю.
Після того, як він пропав, ми нічого не кажемо, але ми відчуваємо.
Ми дуже хотіли б, щоб ви допомогли нам їх знайти.
Їх усіх. Вони всі наші. Немає "мого", "їхнього" - ми всі одні.
Перепрошую за сльози, але кожну хвилину щось робиш,
їсиш просто механічно. Але разом з тим думаєш,
чи їла твоя дитина... Лягаєш спати і думаєш,
а де твоє дитя лягає, а чи воно взагалі спить?
Нерідко рідним доводиться шукати своїх близьких у моргах.
Деякі тіла настільки понівечені, що доводиться здавати ДНК-тести,
як у цій київській лабораторії.
Для батьків, насправді, краще, щоб не було збігів.
Бо вони вірять, що він або живий, або в полоні, або зараз прийде.
За останніми даними, понад 7 тисяч військових
вважаються зниклими безвісти. А разом з цивільними
ця кількість уже перевищує 10 тисяч.
У часи війни держава не справляється з їхнім розшуком.
Тому активно підключаються різні волонтерські ініціативи.
Одна з них - проєкт "Знайти своїх", який запустила
телеведуча Катерина Осадча. Щомісяця сюди звертаються
тисячі родичів зниклих людей.
Активісти проєкту розшукують їх через найрізноманітніші джерела
- бази даних евакуйованих, списки поранених у лікарнях,
списки людей у бомбосховищах, локальні держустанови
на місцях, і навіть через представників так званих "ДНР/ЛНР".
Ця база даних налічує більше ніж сто тисяч людей.
Ми одразу людину шукаємо в цій базі даних, можливо,
десь схоже прізвище, чи ця людина, можливо,
десь була переміщена. І це вже ниточка
і зачіпка для рідних. Тому ми така ланка.
Ланка, що об'єднує людей з інформацією, і ланка,
що намагається знайти людей на місцях.
За словами Осадчої, ще один виклик - це цивільні українці
у полоні росіян. Ворожа сторона не тільки захоплює
неозброєних людей, але й видає їх за військових,
щоб поповнити свій обмінний фонд.
Це роблять з тією метою, що вони не мають права
тримати в полоні цивільних. Немає в світі права
тримати в полоні цивільних. Ну що це?
Це рабство. Це просто... Ну, власне, це злочин
проти гуманітарного права, проти людства.
У нас дійсно є цьому докази, у нас є інтерв'ю з людьми,
я брала інтерв'ю у мами, яка чекає свого сина,
цивільного сина з полону. Разом з ним у полоні був хлопець,
якого обміняли і який розповідав це. Тому, так, це правда.
Микола Полозов - адвокат, який працював над поверненням
українських моряків з полону в РФ у 2018 році.
Тепер його команда розшукує українських військовополонених.
За словами правозахисника, одна з основних проблем -
відсутність даних про українських полонених. На відміну від України,
Росія не сформувала інформаційно-довідкове бюро
щодо військовополонених. Це порушує норми міжнародного
гуманітарного права, однак Кремль пояснює це тим,
що ніякої війни Росія не веде.
Очевидно, що російська влада намагається приховати
ті злочини, які відбуваються щодо військовополонених.
А нам відомо, що їх і катують, і морять голодом,
і роблять інші жахливі речі, які ми дізнаємося від тих полонених,
які все ж потрапили на обмін та були звільнені.
Полозов зазначає, що кількість військовополонених по обидва боки
вже наближається до цифр Другої світової війни.
Правозахисник вважає, що більшість полонених вдасться обміняти.
Для інших необхідно організовувати правозахисну підтримку
у рамках російського законодавства.
Зокрема цим опікується і команда Полозова.
Зрозуміло, що сім тисяч людей вони не будуть переслідувати.
Система не здатна перетравити таку кількість кримінальних справ.
Тобто йтиметься про командирів, про деяких представників полку "Азов",
про якісь медійні постаті, які російська пропаганда
демонізуватиме. Щодо решти, то вони швидше за все підуть на обмін.
Тому що сенсу утримувати їх, окрім бажання не допустити повернення
на передову, у Росії немає. А ось ті, щодо кого фабрикуватимуть
кримінальні справи, так… Мабуть, для них буде набагато
складніше організовувати звільнення.
Складно буде організувати звільнення з РФ і для мирних
українців. Адже військовополонені мають міжнародно закріплений
статус - на відміну від цивільних.
Як владі міняти військових і цивільних? І це, напевно,
найжахливіше, що можна уявити. Якщо хлопець військовий
чи дівчина, то військового на військового зрозуміло,
як обміняти. А як обміняти цивільного?
Також, за інформацією Катерини Осадчої, українських цивільних
полонених утримують у нелюдських умовах, іноді навіть в одній камері
з російськими злочинцями. Це підтверджує і Микола Полозов.
Питання з цивільними стоїть дуже гостро, тому що вони в цьому
випадку не підпадають під ці списки обміну.
Звертатися у випадку з цивільними можна, зокрема,
до російських правозахисників. Наскільки мені відомо,
деяких цивільних утримують взагалі без суду
та слідства у російських СІЗО.
Попри всі труднощі процес обміну між Україною і Росією відбувається,
а пошук зниклих безвісти триває.
Лише в рамках проєкту "Знайти своїх" за останній місяць вдалося
розшукати майже півсотні людей. Катерина Осадча радить:
якщо у вас зникла близька людина, треба "тягнути за всі ниточки":
повідомити у поліцію, у Національне інформаційне бюро,
звернутися до кол-центру Уповноваженого з питань осіб
зниклих безвісти, співпрацювати з волонтерами.
І не втрачати надію на повернення рідної людини.